[Music]
as we come to the end of 2020
the pandemic has had a huge impact and
our world will never be the same
from the way we work socialize travel
and even move about on a day-to-day
basis as an
online fitness creator i wanted to find
out how cov19
has impacted the health and fitness
industry and also
what's the future of fitness going to be
like well i think covered 19
has really hit the fitness industry hard
globally more difficult than we ever
could have imagined this is something
that
nobody could have foreseen of course
they thought they were doing really well
and like
everything is great and then boom this
covert hit since the outbreak earlier
this year
the damage has been devastating for the
brick and mortar gyms
franchises boutique fitness studios and
independently owned fitness centers
during the lockdown gyms and fitness
studios were forced to close
so when kobe came everything just went
when we were shot it was shambles it was
it was
we weren't in a good position i think
everyone felt like it was a little bit
of a game
at first like everyone's at home and
we're communicating via zoom and we're
having zoom parties and things like that
trying to
keep everyone uplifted but it just went
on for
too long and then it was
the uncertainty of what next fitness
centers
all around felt the impact with the
sudden pause
ooh okay that it's it's been tough i'd
be lying to say that
uh that that it's been great wow before
the lockdown
there were aircon turn on i could pay
for the electricity bill
i had staff i had jobs
i had to figure things out to survive
for the next three months and in fact
it just kept getting extended we didn't
know how long it would be
even class pass a fitness booking app
that was
valued at 1 billion dollars in early
january
saw their revenue evaporate in april as
fitness studios around the globe were
affected
we have been almost
95 down on revenue compared to what we
forecast
we were forced to lay off several
hundred
staff in april and essentially cobit
happened and we
we reacted very quickly but we also
recognized the seriousness of it so we
decided okay how can we limit
our operational expenditure as much as
possible
we we tore up our leases to every office
we had in the world
and we just tried to ultimately
almost batten down the hatches to make
sure that we were there
in a postcoded world as strong as
possible with a balance sheet that's as
healthy as possible to help
our studio partners and our fitness
partners and our wellness planners
the impact has been the hardest for the
small businesses
and this included the independently
owned fitness centers
as they had limited financial resources
and support
one such business is house of champions
i opened this gym
uh with a few partners at first and
eventually i bought them all out so i'm
a
sole owner of house of champions i think
i was in a denial
that i wasn't depressed but i think i
was very stressed
and very depressed i had nobody to
talk to so i was constantly just in my
head
what to do what to do what to do what to
do and i couldn't figure out what to do
because
no one has ever gone through such such a
pandemic before and
and no one actually wrote a book of how
to survive a pandemic
many small business owners poured their
life savings into their companies to get
them started
and most of them do not have more than a
month or two
of cash on reserve and when covet hit
they had zero income i think the biggest
challenge
right now that some of the smaller gyms
are facing
the owner operators are facing are is
that
they possibly didn't see the importance
of having that monthly residual income
that most big fitness centers have so
most big fitness centers
have the system where you pay monthly
and you pay
you know every month multi-month and
you're on a minimum term right and some
of these boutique fitness centers are
pay as you go
the bulk of the money for us back then
was our walk-in
we had about 40 to 50
walk-ins a day as a small business we do
rely on the sort of day-to-day
earnings that we make right if you don't
attend class that means
you don't pay fees right so that becomes
the the loss of income to the company
so there isn't any residual income
coming in
i had to ask for some some i don't know
how you want to call it donations for
members
we even looked at renting some of our
equipment
we literally thought of you know
a number of things to to just
cover our costs that was the only thing
we were thinking about not even
profitability anymore it's more
survivability
as the lockdown dragged on about 58
of fitness trainers lost some or all the
income
and around 23 were laid off it was for
me
really really stressful like a mentally
for me to in an active life
to be just locked down between my my
four walls they
pretty much make their money through um
commissions
and when the gym is closed we also
cannot provide that
the biggest mistake i felt fitness
trainers did
during that time they always hope for
this two two week lockdown to end
every two window lockdown they hope that
this is going to end
so that the income would uh rekindle
back
but i never thought it would others took
efforts into their own hands to help the
fitness industry survive the pandemic
we launched a petition to try and get as
many secrets as possible for various
governments around the world to help
save the fitness industry
we launched a donation campaign so our
users could
choose to donate their class class
credits to studios and class class maps
those donations
and we also launched a live stream
product to try and generate excess
excess revenue for our studios who were
forced to go from in person to online
we didn't take commissions from that as
well and probably the thing i'm
most proud of is just how quick we were
to pause that billing
of our users as the lockdown kept being
extended
for some gym owners things started to
look bleak it was tough it was really
tough
i think during the second month of
lockdown
i sort of made up my mind that i was
gonna shut the gym down
i i don't think i would be able to come
back from this uh
all the money that i've invested into
the gym i don't think i'll be able to
see it anymore because at that point
i was owing the gym the landlord
two to three months rent which was about
twenty thousand ringgit and i'm like if
i were to continue to reinvest in the
company
that means i just give myself even more
problem
so i thought you know what just cut the
losses here
pull the plug dennis's last resort was
to reach out to his community for help
and support
i'm so flustered and so like so like
just all messed up in my head it was all
just
entangled intertwined in my head and
then i did that video i just said you
know what just
record uh because i need your support
i need your help i need i need
i need a direction guys i'm so sorry
because i'm i'm just
in a very i'm very lost
right now because i'm all alone
immediately after i posted that video a
lot of messages came in a lot of my
friends
messaged me members messaged me and
even other gym owners messaged me as
well
to to sort of like share their thoughts
and some of them actually gave me some
really good advice
wow you know the support is there you
know people really don't want to see you
die
during the lockdown gyms and fitness
studios were forced
to close or go digital curvy 19 has
forced us to exercise indoors the almost
100 billion dollars fitness industry has
pivoted
into an online model literally overnight
in january of this year before the
pandemic we actually
shot 1700 workout videos so individual
exercises
we were able to repurpose those
exercises and create
online workouts so that happened within
10 days of lockdown which is quite a
phenomenal speed to turn around and put
out some online workout we said okay
let's quickly spin up
a functionality now app whereby our
studio partners can list
live stream classes in the same way they
list in person classes whether it's a
zoom link or
a custom url and then we send all of
that revenue
through to our studio partners so we
were getting upwards of 15
000 reservations per day on
livestream which is a reasonably
compelling number
and the reception was really positive
but yeah we were able to spin that up
in two to three weeks flat
social media has since been flooded with
online workouts from gyms to studios
personal trainers anyone and everyone
during this pandemic i've also seen a
tremendous growth on my youtube channel
there has been a higher demand for home
workouts and my views
have doubled sales of fitness equipment
and technology
have grown at record levels along with
subscriptions for online classes and
streaming fitness services
downloads of health and fitness apps
grew by 46
worldwide from the first half of 2020.
india saw the highest increase in
downloads rising by 156
that translate to 58 million new active
users
almost double the population of malaysia
i've also seen an increase in
subscribers on my own fitness app called
few as more people were doing the
on-demand workouts and
shared their progress for the online
workout i'm doing
six days a week i
got back in a shape that i had
like about 10 years ago and my mood is
lifted up
for me is is no excuses anymore
one of the most overlooked groups during
these trying times
are our kids in young children and
adolescents the pandemic and lockdown
have a greater impact on their emotional
and social development
compared to the adults in recent surveys
by save the children
up to 65 percent of children struggled
with
boredom anxiety and feelings of
isolation
the whole thing of being locked up in a
house i think it's quite hard for
children to understand
what's going on and as parents we do all
we can to protect them
and try to keep some sort of normalcy in
support of the parents and kids at home
marisa the owner of a kids capoeira
academy
continued their lessons online the
response was really amazing so i would
say about
85 of the parents got their kids to come
online
now obviously teaching a group of kids
in front of the camera
can be a challenge you've got to up it i
mean the energy that you've got to give
through screen right because there's
none of that
that physical connection that you have
and
the kids are you know it's easy for them
now to lose attention and then you've
just got to be really sharp
and basically really plan your lesson so
that you can
keep their attention the kids just loved
it we got so many messages from parents
saying
the kids are loving the class they
really look forward to this
[Music]
however not every fitness trainer was
willing or had
the confidence to adapt and shift their
business online
they have this inferiority complex
of not feeling they are good enough to
step in front of
the other brands and just be adam
or andy they feel they have to hide
behind a brand
to sort of build their confidence so we
did a little training session
on teaching the camera we shot small
snippets we gave them feedback
and i think the coolest thing was some
of our newest trainers were the ones who
put their hands up and said oh hey i'll
give this a shot
you know so that was really exciting
because people that had only been
teaching
for us for a short period of time before
lockdown they were some of the first to
come forward and say i want to do that
i really like that gung-ho attitude and
so giving them a little bit of
training really helped them for those
who adapted and embraced online coaching
they were able to rekindle their
finances and have said that they would
even continue coaching online
post pandemic it has an opportunity for
me to try to
develop even more skills in terms of
like the way that i coach the way that i
co
iq i have been able to train people in
different parts of the world
so that helps me a lot in terms of okay
financially because i
started getting like the the incomes
again like mentally because i was having
again
interaction with people so definitely
from frustration was to a new
opportunity to do something different
some people were extremely grateful for
the online home workouts
as it kept them healthy physically
mentally
and emotionally it's been like super
cool i did it for myself
and i just started to see a lot of
change on me on my body and on my mental
health
and on my awesome work day motivation
like like stick to myself it's like
really
fat oh my god if they do with me then i
can do that too
i can make them proud that i can do it
at home there are definitely people out
there that were grateful for the
opportunity to see their trainer online
and do workouts from home
you do get a lot of feedback from from
followers who share their ig
stories of them being thankful for
having someone to
to follow because they lack the drive
themselves most of the time on the flip
side
really allowed me to re-engage with my
audiences on a personal basis
and that was very fulfilling
as restrictions eased and people were
allowed to go outdoors
some saw this as a great opportunity to
venture into something
new and exciting oxygen cycle is kuala
lumpur's
first outdoor rooftop spin studio
and they started during the pandemic it
took us two weeks to set up
the whole studio registration get the
bikes
um i was so determined that time
i told my team guys i don't care two
weeks there's no such thing as
impossible right i don't believe that
there's no solution to any form of
scenario i like to take the challenge
i've always been type of person
ayman has learned to embrace the
situation and work
with it rather than against it since the
launch of oxygen cycle mid this year
the demand has grown and they now have
close to 2
000 registered cyclists this is one form
of spin studio where you don't have
mirrors
it's just you and an instructor you're
not you're not in a tight room where
everything's blacked out you cannot see
on this you get to really connect and
visually see everyone
so you become more honest more grounded
i feel like it's a very humbling moment
we've also seen people getting together
and creating their own fitness community
and that's how academy 56 came about so
it began with two people
and then after that it just kind of
snowballed it was just a bunch of people
saying okay you know what let's get
together and work out
people just want to come out and commune
and just
interact with people again especially
after being isolated for so long
we get together we work out together we
push each other and then from there we
actually build different relationships
so as state at home orders were
gradually lifted across the globe
fitness centers were allowed to operate
again
the struggles are expected to continue
in getting people back
in a survey by run repeat revealed that
only
30.98 of members returned
after the gyms reopened we are part of
the solution we are really part of the
solution
fitness is part of this it's not part of
the problem you you build up your
immunity
you build up your cardiovascular
strength cardiovascular endurance
improve your state of mind i think
number one with with reopening you just
need the
the trust from your members you need to
like the whole time during the mco the
three months we were shot
uh i told the team that number one we
just need to be transparent
and we need to make sure communication
is is done very well
but it's not all negative there are
people who are hungry to come back
to the gym and get back into their
fitness routine 95
of our users in asia that we've
convinced to come back
into a studio in the last three months
95
say they're going to work out as much or
more
than they did pre-coping we were
quite surprised to be honest our loyal
members came back
90 of our parents really want the kids
to come back
i think they have a lot of they have a
lot of trust in us they see that we've
they see what we've done in the space in
terms of you know minimizing the class
numbers
applying implementing all the sops
keeping it safe for the kids and i think
for
them it's the mental wellness that
tops it they they want their kids to be
engaged
as for dennis although he had the
support from his members and reopened
his gym
he has had to lay off all his stuff
and manage everything on his own i sat
here every single day for one whole
month for 12 hours
but thankfully at that point my mom came
in and said boy
you cannot continue like that you're
gonna kill yourself your container
because i was not getting enough sleep
stress over my head all the weight on my
shoulders
so my mom said why not mom and dad
they'll take
they'll take care of the morning session
and then i'll come in about three four
o'clock and take care of the night
[ __ ] session so we have sort of like a
two shifting i actually told my mom i
said that's
that's one of the things that i hate the
most is that my mom and dad have to sit
in front of the gym
for me i told them that it's never my
plan and that my mom and dad they're
really really supportive
they're really really supportive i
cannot say thank you enough whether or
not the recovery in health and fitness
clubs
is v-shaped or u-shaped
will likely depend partly on how
effectively studios
execute their reopening strategies one
of the key things that
gyms are going to need in order to
continue to strive is
they have to do whatever they do very
well but if you have a
aaa team who are willing to work willing
to put in the extra hours
a little bit to do putting a little bit
more effort for customer service
then it makes these challenging times a
little bit easier
i think we could see positive uptick
in six months time and potentially
where we would like to be by the end of
2021
although there has been a decline in gym
memberships
most fitness centers have seen a
positive uptick in personal training
more than ever people are realizing the
importance
of looking after their health so with
little to no effort like pt really
boomed
and we said okay let's double down on
on that side of things we really believe
that if you're
focused on delivering a good personal
training experience whether it's
boxing or fitness training or
high intensity training we know that
having that personal training
those personal training members getting
results we know they're going to stay
longer
as a fitness coach myself i've been
creating workout videos online for the
past
seven years and i've been able to build
a strong connection with my followers
online
and make a difference in their lives i
know the positive impact it can have
even though my presence is virtual
nowadays
online is is something that it's real
you know it's something that
is not just digitalis you can feel that
connection
now i teach over 20 classes online per
week at least
i couldn't have predicted that i would
start to really like
the online teaching or the virtual
teaching
obviously stepping into fio gave me that
opportunity to try it out you know
would i feel the same about presenting a
workout when i can't see the people in
front of me
and i can honestly say it comes from a
place of knowing that i'm making a
difference no matter what
you know whether i've got people in
front of me or whether there are people
at home watching this video through the
app or through youtube or whatever the
forum is
if they're able to get fit and healthy
then i'm fulfilling my purpose
which is to help people get fit and
healthy
one thing we can all agree is that this
pandemic
has changed the fitness industry forever
so what can we expect
post pandemic is digital fitness here to
stay
or a home-based workout program's just a
passing fed i think
online business for sure is going to
surge right online business will
continue to grow
and the thing that's going to be
separating the winners and the ones who
don't do so well is
is the type of content that's going to
be produced right and how much
interaction you have with your users or
how much content or how much interaction
you have
with your followers you know the
conversation has been around a long time
a lot longer than when the pandemic hit
the conversation around you know what's
the effectiveness of online workouts
um you know who does these online
workouts if they're doing online
workouts are they not coming to our
clubs
so it's almost been like they're two
completely separate conversations and
now they've
come together and they have to work it
out and nobody really has the answer
but i believe that both businesses are
important
so i do believe that the at-home
online experience whichever way it goes
especially with technology is just going
to get stronger and stronger and i think
technology companies are realizing that
there's a real opportunity with fitness
and health
now the market valuation of online
fitness is expected
to cross 30 billion dollars by 2026
thanks to the rising health concerns
coupled with the growing penetration of
internet connectivity as more people are
shifting to exercise in the comfort of
their own homes
some may still not feel safe going back
to the fitness center
does that also mean that digital fitness
will eventually take over the in-studio
experience
i hope not i hope not for the sake of
the industry
and all of the trainers who depend on
the income i still see myself going out
outdoors wherever it may be engaging i
like the engagement
i like the physical engagement of
individuals at the gym
or outdoors or indoors like the studio
is always like
you know it's it's feel alive like the
the real shouting of the people
like the the the real vibes you're in
the studio you've got
you've got the music you've got the vibe
you've got you know the instructor
yelling at you you know you've got your
your squad your friends and when you
don't feel like working out you've got
someone next to you
and you think oh my god no now i've got
to do you know i've got to lift heavy
i've got to run faster
it's safe to say that the in-studio
experience will
never be replaced by digital fitness but
digital fitness is poised to get even
stronger
in the future so how important is it for
businesses
to have a presence in both and which
will the industry
lean towards i think there's space for
both
i like the online business because the
scalability
right if you can deliver something and
you can make it
have that incredible experience it's
very easy to scale
but having both products now gives us
the opportunity to expand
outside our local market and go
international with virtual and
retain our local relationships with our
fans here
in studio so we have both parts of the
business now digital has opened up
the volume of people who are interested
in working out at home
who maybe never would have considered it
before but it's not going to be a
replacement to the in-person experience
it's going to be complementary
everything's kind of being lifted at the
moment
because people are seeing more
importance
of taking care of themselves self-care
whether it's
self-care of your mind self-care of your
body
nutrition i think all those things now
people have really focused on so they're
definitely not going to stay awake
whether you go in studio whether you go
online you just
choose the thing that works for you
because no matter which option you
choose it's going to be good
so which experience would you guys
choose leave a comment below
many small businesses are still
operating at limited capacity or
have completely shuttered so for those
who are thinking of opening up
a new gym or studio is this
the right time you want to buy a house
with champions of mine
okay i i will always encourage people to
take a challenge move forward especially
these hard times when
you can't wait you know those times of
you waiting is already high risk why
don't you
take that time of waiting and that high
risk into something
trying to make something happen you need
to get me and right now you think this
is the craziest time to open up a gym
but rentals are a little bit more
affordable spaces are becoming more
available so
i think if you're going to open up a gym
maybe you may
wait a little bit but make sure you have
the right team you're gonna have to love
this more than money if you want to open
a gym
like this because i can tell you if you
don't have
you don't have unlimited money or
resources
it's really hard to sustain a business
like this
there's a lot of moving parts it's not
just you put in some equipment
you make it beautiful and then all of a
sudden people are just going to be
knocking on your door
waiting to join your gym if you have a
good plan and if you have
a lot of capital to get you through
challenging times
and you can deliver something that is
exceptional
and you're confident that you can do it
you have a great sales team
which is very important right now you
have great marketing
i think right now is a decent time to
open up a gym
but take it with precaution of the
the um the outcome you know if things
doesn't work out the anticipation but i
think either way
based on weather sunshine whatever
there's always obstacles in business in
these challenging times
we need each other more than ever and it
has been
really beautiful to witness the fitness
community
coming together and supporting each
other knowing that
we're going to get through this together
and come out stronger
this is unity at its best and i want to
see more unity
between gyms between the people
between business owners and i think that
has really happened
probably one of the biggest joys is the
coming together of quite a few studios
to support each other
you know there was there's always that
little edge of competition between
one boutique and another but we're all
servicing the same customer base i think
this whole adversity actually made our
team stronger
we got closer to each other because we
realized that
that we needed to to work together to
make things
to make sure things work it's just
amazing to see that
a lot of people in this industry really
didn't give up during this period and
it really helps the industry
moving forward covet 19 has turned our
lives
upside down and changed not just the way
we live and work
but also how we think and behave every
part of the world has been affected
and every aspect of life have been
impacted
while we reflect back on this year there
are some life lessons
to take away from this pandemic one of
the takeaways i did not know the year's
ending really
bloody hell we didn't even get to enjoy
this year bloody hell
biggest takeaway pissed off as hell i
don't think 2020 is a write-off
i think 2020 is actually a very
important year a lot of people have dive
deep to
ask themselves am i really doing what
i'm meant to be doing
i think people will start to
be more humble i i want to teach myself
to enjoy life
because one thing that i learned in this
pandemic is that life is short
you never know when you're gonna go and
when this is gonna happen or that's
gonna happen so
why worry about what's gonna happen the
next 20 years when you did not even live
in the present a wonderful reminder
of being present the present is all we
have
the past is gone the future is still to
come and
we just need to absorb what's here in
front of us in this moment
i had way too much on my plate uh with
various events that i was trying to sort
of uh
slow down a little bit don't know how to
slow it down
but covet gave me
in disguise opportunity to just scrap
the the plate clean
uh really spend time with my my family
and kids
and allow me to have a new beginning a
new awakening
for different things in life so in that
sense it has been very
blessed as cliche as it sounds it's just
don't give up
there is always a solution leaders find
a way
and if one thing doesn't work do what
you can to figure out
the next solution there is always a
silver lining in everything
and to always remind each other i think
there's something that we need to do
constantly and is to remind each other
to be grateful and one thing that i've
learned is actually just to be
compassionate
because you never know what that other
person
believes in what they're going through
and i just think in general
in in all aspects of life whether we're
going through a pandemic or not it's
compassion the awareness in health and
fitness has grown tremendously
and the fitness industry isn't showing
any signs of slowing down
so as we move forward it is my hope
that each and every one of us will
continue to stay fit and healthy
whether it's at home outdoors in studio
or through digital fitness it is more
important
now than ever that we prioritize our
health
hi i'm tracy mona all right bye fitness
thanks to kovit i'm not insurance agent
hey kate can i swear or not
yeah you can but yeah have an
hour late they can well they can still
come they will still die
you